we had a multiple agency federal raid on
oaksterdam university as well as our
museum and the gift shop and Richard
LEAs qualified dispensary that's
actually permitted by the City of
Oakland it was a tough day for
oaksterdam I think the thing that they
underestimate is when they act like this
usually galvanizes our base better than
anything that we can do with every ounce
of energy that we have I'm incredibly
disappointed in the Obama
administration's breaking of the promise
that they made to the medical cannabis
community to respect state medical
cannabis laws to me it's truly
inexplicable I can't think of any good
reason political moral or legal for them
to go back on that promise and it's just
been a terribly disillusioning
experience not just for me but for many
people within the medical cannabis
community it's a sad it's a sad day in a
way that in a sense to know that the
people that are in the streets today and
we're in the streets yesterday are
people who are dealing with a lot of
other issues besides just their medicine
and you know the victory in our movement
will mean the patient's live just like
anyone else all right the only time we
have to think about our medication is
when we take it we have qualified
medical cannabis dispensaries that are
taking cannabis off the streets the
profits away from these violent dealers
and we can take this money out of the
drug war and actually give it to the
officers to go fight the bad guys and
just as a mother I hope that other
mothers understand
that it's not this plant that's
dangerous its prohibition